all right today is a very special day it
is the birthday of david pakman show
producer and marketing extraordinaire
noah ferguson and what we are doing
today to celebrate noah Ferguson's
birthday i don't think he knows we're
doing this we had to sort of keep it
quiet with the internal systems that i
used and we had to throw out some false
flags to prevent him from knowing about
it
I know a Ferguson used to be a caller to
the David Pakman show
and I went back and found a voicemail
that he left for us about seven years
ago before he was an intern before he
was a part-time employee before he was a
full-time employee and I'm gonna play it
for you and I know that he's aware of
this voicemail and he also says that he
doesn't stand by some of the things that
he says in the voicemail okay let's take
a listen to this classic voicemail that
once made it on the show from current
david pakman show producer noah ferguson
on his birthday take a listen hey david
lewis and that other guy just kidding
painted on noah here from richmond
virginia i had a question for you guys
I've only been listening to the show for
about a year so right so I'm not really
sure if you've addressed this before but
I was wondering living in a state that
Obama was guaranteed to win such as
Massachusetts
if you ever considered voting for a more
progressive third party candidate like
Jill Stein or Stuart Alexander not
because they had any chance of winning
but I guess in hope of giving them a
little more attention and possibly even
some data voice on the mainstream stage
maybe years and years and years from now
as opposed to voting for Obama who I've
heard you say many times it's not
progressive enough of course living in a
battleground state like Virginia I voted
for Obama to avoid a Romney presidency
but I was wondering what your coding
strategies are as progressives living in
a solidly blue state and then you think
the Democrats will become more
progressive with time in the best way to
promote that is to give them a larger
percentage of the vote I don't know just
hoping to get your order thoughts on
that all right so thank you guys I enjoy
the show pretty word so as you can tell
I would rank this voicemail
at about a 7.5 yes he was not on
speakerphone he had good signal we could
hear him clearly he inserted a lot of
questions into it and it did carry on a
little bit but this was a completely
novice Noah Ferguson calling in so I
think that if he were to call into the
show today he would not leave such a
long voicemail oh yeah I mean he has he
had a lot of practice in the mean time
so I think if he wants to do this again
it would be a lot higher quality no
question about it but still about a 7.5
and happy birthday to know he's doing
great great work on the show and
congratulations to him for having had a
voicemail played on the show
seven years ago I like how he said hey
David Lewis and that other guy I mean
that's pretty funny who's that other guy
well that was a thing that was happening
at the time uncle would call in and
refer to NAT on as the other guy and so
he was kind of playing that up he knew
who the other guy was as he said hey NAT
on what's going on happy birthday no up
we've got a great bonus show for you
join it join pakman.com